[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je suis très heureux de
vous retrouver pour ce 7,8 sport
l'émission consacrée à l'actualité
sportive dans le département c'est parti
opte pour le sommaire rugby dans le
championnat honneur versailles s'est
largement imposé contre clairement à
l'occasion de la 15e journée
les versaillais l'ont emporté 39 à 8 et
reste à portée de la deuxième place le
résumé du match est à retrouver dans
quelques instants
aviron le chesnaysiens thomas baruch
sort avec ou dans ce magazine le sportif
licencié au cercle nautique de
versailles et médaillé de bronze aux
derniers jo de rio reviendra sur ses
objectifs et sur les régates de versets
qui sont organisées ce dimanche 18 mars
dans le parc du château pour s'appuyer
la 11e édition de l'eco trail est
organisée ce week-end avec au programme
de la marche nordique des randonnées et
des traits de 18 30 45 km c'est un
dernier de 80 km celui-ci partira ce
samedi de l'île des loisirs de saint
quentin en yvelines pour rejoindre la
tour eiffel tous les détails dans cette
émission
coup de projecteur à présent sur les
principaux résultats sportifs du
week-end dans le département
[Musique]
mais avant de développer ces titres un
mot de la ryder cup 2018 les
organisateurs de la compétition viennent
de dévoiler les plans de la future
tribune qui bordera le départ du trou
numéro 1 sur l'albatros du golf national
de saint quentin en yvelines
les chiffres donnent le tournis plus de
6600 48 supporters pourront prendre
place en tribune une capacité d'accueil
qui permettra cette immense arène de
devenir la plus grande jamais construite
pour cette compétition
en comparaison la tribune de la dernière
ryder cup à hazeltine ne pouvait
contenir que mille six cent soixante
huit personnes au total l'événement
devrait attirer près de soixante mille
supporters chaque jour sur le site du 28
au 30 septembre prochain une tribune que
l'une des plus grandes figures du golf
de l'histoire pourra apercevoir je veux
bien sûr parler de tiger woods le tigre
sera présent fin septembre sur les
greens du golf national de saint quentin
en yvelines pour la ryder cup
l'homme aux 14 grands chelems vient
d'être retenu par le capitaine jim
flohic son ancien coéquipier et grand
ami pour être le vice capitaine de
l'équipe américaine face aux joueurs
européens
woods pourrait toutefois être joueur sur
cette compétition si ces résultats
continuent à s'améliorer
on écoute sa réaction publiée sur les
réseaux sociaux qui en tout cas de son
meilleur niveau et pourrait jouer devant
les supporters de saint quentin en
yvelines le tigre a terminé à ce
week-end à deuxième place du championnat
valls par un coup derrière le vainqueur
quasi son meilleur résultat lors d'un
tournoi officiel depuis 2013 il entre
par la même occasion dans le top 500 50
mondial
on ouvre une page rugby à présent versé
n'a pas connu de soucis ce week-end sur
son teint pour venir à bout de l'équipe
de clermont à l'occasion de la 15e
journée du championnat de division
honneur les versaillais l'ont emporté 39
à 8 dans un match où la manière n'était
pas forcément au rendez vous le résumé
du match les images sont signés à
patrick jacques de dixmude un versailles
efficace ce dimanche 11 mars dans leur
stade de porchefontaine les jours de la
cité royale troisième de 10
vision longtemps portées contre le 5e
clermont avec à la clé six s inscrit de
point de bonus offensif ce camp final 39
à 8,20 match de reprise on a voulu déjà
gagné ce match ça s'est fait avec le
bonus lors on est content on restera
voilà sur cinq matches avec bonus
offensif formé à 30 à 40 points de
moyenne à sur les cinq derniers matches
mais au-delà du résultat la prestation
collective dé versailles et sur cette
rencontre n'a pas été séduisante aux
yeux du stuff conseillère match de
reprise on a pas de rythme c'est normal
d'accord il faut bosser la circulation
fin si l'utilisation du ballon latitude
dans les contacts ont été projetés du
doigt par l'entraîneur will do ritmo
fait donc la part on a eu du mal à
enchaîner 3 4 temps de jeu et à mettre
du rythme dans le match et puis on est
tombé dans une bouillie de rugby en
faisant trop de fautes quoi sera fait
demain les mauvais placements sont
ovales et un vrai besoin de retravailler
portait robot industriel est forcément
aujourd'hui on veut vraiment réussir
avec des choses en place d'ici la fin de
saison je pense que ça passe par de la
rigueur est fou et le coach est un peu
dur mais c'est c'est normal puisqu'on
est capable de produits proposés
puisqu'on a propose aujourd'hui je pense
que l'on pouvait beaucoup mieux faire
pour corriger ces approximations les
versailles ont rendez vous ce dimanche
18 mars à 15 heures ils affronteront
chevreuse pour le derby évinois de ce
championnat honneur
on continue par du rugby toujours dans
le championnat de division honneur dans
un match capital dans la course à la
montée le sky rugby n'a rien pu n
avaient rien pu faire sur le terrain du
rc paris à l'occasion de la 15e journée
du championnat les joueurs de thomas
payen se sont inclinés 30 à 16 7
défaites les fait entrer dans la zone de
relégation à cinq journées de la fin de
la saison et saint-quentinoise son 9e
sur 10 mais avec un match en moins dans
le championnat de promotion honneur
montigny-le-bretonneux s'est incliné de
justesse ce dimanche à l'extérieur sur
le terrain de champagne saint-andré
verger score final 29 à 24 une
contre-performance face à l'avant
dernier du classement
les y montrent un reste ancré à la 6e
place avec un bilan de cinq victoires et
8 défaites depuis le début de la saison
prochain match dimanche prochain sur le
terrain de montesson un match de
handball féminin présent dans ce
championnat de nationale 2 montigny le
bretonneux acquis une courte mais
précieuse victoire ce week-end sur son
terrain contre palaiseau le score 22 à
21 grâce notamment à cinq buts inscrits
par mélanie najlae au classement lésigny
monteyne ne compte plus que quatre
points de retard
le premier relégable saint maur la
remonte à dan est plus que jamais
envisageable
une fois n'est pas coutume nous allons
maintenant ouvrir une page
aviron dans ce set 8 sport coup de
projecteur aujourd'hui sur le versailles
et thomas baruch médaillé de bronze aux
derniers jeux olympiques de rio
nous avons la chance de le recevoir sur
cette émission et il est venu avec sa
médaille de bronze
bonsoir thomas baruch ben ça alors nous
vous invitons aujourd'hui car les
saisons se suivent mais ne se
ressemblent pas forcément pour vous pour
comprendre retourne arrière vous avez
été donc médaille de bronze en quatre de
pointe sans barreur poids léger mais
vous aviez fait de le choix l'an dernier
de basculer dans toutes catégories suite
à une décision du comité international
olympique et de supprimer les épreuves
du programme de gio le dock you et douze
mois plus tard vous avez décidé de faire
un nouveau volte-face et de revenir en
poids léger pourquoi avez vous pris
cette décision alors je reviens au poids
légers mais j'ai quand même des petits
changements cercueil llodra mais avec
une seule âme gérard hamel drame puisque
le seul bateau olympique qui reste chez
les poids légers c'est un dos de couple
donc deux rameurs avec deux rames chacun
pourquoi j'ai pris cette décision bien
tout simplement parce que c'était celle
qu'ils m'offraient les perspectives
sportives les plus intéressantes et au
delà de ça c'est aussi celle qui me
plaisait le plus en termes d'aviron pur
c'est à dire que c'est dans ces bateaux
là avec ce groupe d'athlètes là que j'ai
pu prendre le plus de plaisir en bateau
et c'est quand même le principal vous
avez sentiment d'avoir perdu un an de
votre carrière
alors ça va sans doute falloir attendre
un petit peu plus pour le dire c'est sûr
que quand on se retourne comme ça à
chaud on a un peu l'impression qu
effectivement si on avait pris une autre
décision
on aurait peut-être fait une saison dans
un bateau non olympique aussi mais en
gagnant beaucoup plus de médailles que
ce qu'on a ce que ce qu'on a fait là je
sais pas il va falloir faire le bilan un
peu plus tard vous avez quand même
continué à progresser pendant cette
année clairement oui
c'est pour ça que c'est pas qu'elle a si
clairement pas une année de perdue parce
que physiquement il ya du gros travail
de fait et qui a payé dès cette année là
j'ai gagné près de 5 secondes sur mon
record personnel sur 2000 mètres donc
clairement c1 c'est un grand bond en
avant au niveau physique ce n'est pas
trop compliqué vous aviez dû prendre du
poids pour passer dans la dernière
catégorie là vous allez devoir en perdre
alors je vais pas comme objectif
justement de prendre du poids j'ai comme
objectif de progresser physiquement ce
que je crois avoir fait j'ai
effectivement pris un peu de poids sur
la période
pas trop justement ce qui fait que leurs
toits carrière j'aimerais voilà c'est ça
un petit peu dans ces eaux là
ce qui fait que le retour en arrière est
possible ça a été une décision assez
difficile à prendre parce que clairement
ça d impact sur ma vie au quotidien et
que je n'avais pas forcément envie de
refaire ces sacrifices la pour l'instant
ça se passe bien
surtout que la première partie de la
saison se fait avec une limite de poids
un peu plus élevé
donc pour l'instant s'agira assez
facilement et j'espère que pour la suite
c'est bien aussi
le cercle nautique de versailles vous a
soutenu dans vos choix oui comme celle
de
conseiller wii accompagné on a discuté
ensemble a essayé de peser le pour et le
contre
au delà de juste l'aspect sportif il y
avait aussi tout simplement ma vie
personnelle comment je commence à
envisager les prochaines années est ce
que j'avais envie de faire qu'est ce qui
était réellement important donc oui ils
ont toujours été derrière moi alors vous
avez eu de bons résultats ce week-end à
caen lors des têtes de rivière
interrégional sur 6000 mètres vous vous
êtes imposé avec 12 secondes d'avancé
je me trompe pas c'est pas il s'agissait
de la dernière étape avant les
championnats de france qui seront
programmées les 13 et 15 avril
alors c'est pas tout à fait la dernière
c'est pas tout à fait une étape
intermédiaire à la fin du mois un
championnat de zone donc sur la même
région géographique on va dire que la
tête de rivière qui aura lieu à mantes
la jolie
donc c'est l'une des seules compétitions
que je fais dans la région donc autant
en profiter si vous voulez venir le voir
et du coup cette bonne augure pour
l'astuce effectivement de très bonne
augure en plus le deuxième coup cité à
12 secondes il pas dans ma catégorie des
poids légers et toutes catégories
le premier pôle et gilles à près de 40
secondes donc c'est assez satisfaisant
sur ce résultat la maintenance à préjuge
de rien pour la suite
ce qui compte ce sera les championnats
de france mi avril et vaudra mieux faire
dans les deux premiers quel est votre
objectif maintenant c'est toujours de
participer aux jo de tokyo
voilà l'objectif de long terme c'est
toujours les jeux olympiques à tokyo
fort probablement sauf encore
retournement de situation en deux de
couple poids léger sachant que le bateau
est pour l'instant champion olympique et
champion du monde en titre
on vous garde en plateau pour parler à
des régates de versailles la compétition
l'une des plus grandes courses d'aviron
en france est programmée ce dimanche sur
votre point d'eau d'entraînement dans le
château de versailles 400 bateaux
internationaux à 1500 rameurs et près de
10000 spectateurs sont attendus pour
l'événement vous allez concourir sur ce
rendez vous pourquoi
non malheureusement je vais pas dire
j'ai participé je vais l'organiser je
vais prendre les chronos qui est un
point important de ce c'est comme ça que
se font les qualifications le matin je
vais participent à l'organisation avec
tout le reste du club j'ai quand même
besoin d'une centaine de bénévoles pour
organiser cette manifestation est que
justement c'est mu 500 rameurs puisse
s'exprimer pleinement sur 16 heures
place je serai sur place avec plaisir et
c'est un événement qui regroupe des
catégories de minimes à vétérans en
quatre ou huit
c'est un bon niveau est clairement oui
des rameurs internationaux d'autres
internationaux de la région qui viennent
il ya les meilleurs rameurs de la région
c'est quelques semaines avant les
championnats de france bateaux courts
donc une période où commençait à être en
forme à chercher à faire des
compétitions donc il ya du beau monde
c'est l'occasion aussi de mettre en
avant le cercle nautique de versailles
qui existe depuis 1908 tout à fait
comment savoir quelques années c'est
l'événement majeur de la vie du club et
au delà de ça c'est aussi un très bon
vecteur de mettre en avant notre sport
l'aviron
dans ce cadre magnifique et de permettre
à des gens qui viennent voir le château
de aussi découvrir ce sport un peu par
hasard mais en général quand le temps le
s'y prête
il reste avec plaisir le au bord du
bassin vont passer les bateaux ça attire
de nouveaux licenciés au club
je suis pas sûr je ne suis pas sûr parce
que ça voudrait y voilà ça fait un très
beau spectacle
il ya malheureusement plus de
d'étrangers que de versailles et qui
viennent dans le parc du château le
dimanche et c'est un événement qui peut
attirer tous types de publics tout on
peut venir voir sur mon mini tout le
monde peut venir voir
c'est assez simple à comprendre une
course d'aviron il suffit de le savoir
de regarder qui est devant pour savoir
qui ira en tête et s'en aller dans les
détails techniques c'est quand même très
esthétique avoir sur le bord même quand
on n'y connaît pas grand chose merci à
vous thomas baruch pour votre présence
sur cette étude sport c'était un plaisir
je vous rappelle que les régates de
versets sont programmées à ce dimanche
les courses éliminatoires débutent à
partir de 8h30
cap maintenant sur montigny le
bretonneux judo bushido taekwondo ou
encore aïkido tous ces arts martiaux ont
été présentés au grand public ce samedi
au centre sportif pierre de coubertin de
montigny au programme des initiations
encadrés par les clubs de la commune
propre pour les petits et pour les
grands
les images sont signés à mélanie poké
les gestes sont encore hésitants mais la
volonté est bien présente karaté bushido
tai jitsu encore aïkido des novices ont
pu tester ce samedi 10 mars une dizaine
d'arts martiaux venus des contrées
asiatiques font quatre ans bien j'ai
fait avec lui
fait ça et pourquoi pas toi comme ça
pour les combats je dire les techniques
pour apprendre à se défendre avec les
enfants les adultes se sont également
prêtés au jeu
ils ont appris pendant cette journée a
esquivé à contrer ou à maîtriser des
techniques avec les des clubs locaux
on a essayé le taï shi tzu et ben ça
nous a bien plu puisque on a fait des
exercices au moins 15 différents
ce vote risque une heure on était venus
pour essayer dix minutes un quart
d'heure et puis on est resté j'ai appris
plein de choses aujourd'hui
objectif annoncé de l'événement faire
découvrir les 13 associations d'arts
martiaux de montigny le bretonneux et
surtout convertir les 1000 participants
leur discipline et à des gens qui ont
pris nos coordonnées
ils vont venir enfin ils ont déjà essayé
ici vont venir essayer au sein du club
certains avaient peur parce qu'on leur a
montré beaucoup de technique on leur
expliquait que là aujourd'hui c'est une
initiation leur montrer un panel pour
leur faire goûter pour leur donner envie
mais au sein du club on présente
effectivement qu une deux voire trois
techniques maximum pour qu'ils aient le
temps de se les approprier les maîtriser
pour convaincre définitivement les
débutants encore un peu hésitant la
journée s'est clôturée par un spectacle
sur les différents arts martiaux et des
mises en scène
l'opération séduction devrait avoir
fonctionné on prend maintenant la
direction de coignières pour parler de
judo plus de 200 jeunes âgés de 4 à 12
ans venus d'une vingtaine de clubs du
département se sont affrontés sur les
tatamis du gymnase du moulin à vent pour
cette compétition organisée depuis 2005
pas de résultats officiels mais des
combats pour apprendre on écoute jean
luc desloges professeur de judo à
coignières au micro de patrick jacques
de dixmude alors le but est cette
compétition c'est pour que dans le temps
puisse rencontrer des enfants qui ne
connaissent pas de d'autres clubs et en
même temps qui va prendre un petit peu
plus que c'est que le judo par une
compétition paula ya un arbitre
donc les règles sont un peu plus
expliqué plus facilement parce qu'ils
sont deux passes à une personne un
adulte donc du coup c'est plus facile
pour elle de comprendre on continue par
de la boxe pour la journée de la femme
un stage d'initiation noble art était
organisée ce jeudi
jeudi dernier le 8 mars au complexe
sportif pierre de coubertin de montigny
le bretonneux
au programme de l'aéroboxe et un cours
pour apprendre les techniques de ce
sport parmi les débutantes notre
journaliste mélanie poker puis s'essayer
aux uppercuts et aux crochets du droit à
regarder cinquante six mille à l'essence
est actuellement en 2014 la fédération
française de boxe collé d'une des plus
grosses progressions de féminisation +10
9%
le football et le rugby c'est 5% points
alors pourquoi un tel succès réponse le
ring
[Musique]
je pense que ça peut faire est renforcé
le
les muscles tout ça donc oui ce pourrait
être ma nation je pense que c'est un
milieu plutôt masculin et steq m'attire
aussi pourquoi pas les 6 et la cité
sociale problèmes de la femme donc
donc c'est tout ensemble c'est un sport
on pense pas spécialement à le faire
quand on est une fille nous pour se dire
voilà on s'initie si ça nous plaît en
continu
[Musique]
alors attendre à la salle de boxe mais
par transport nous sommes exactement
c'est aussi un sport de femmes et sont
vraiment toute leur place dans la
discipline et d'ailleurs on a
aujourd'hui tout tout type de pratiques
qui permettent aux femmes de s'adonner
au noble art mais c'est différent
j'imagine c'est pas tout à fait les
mêmes mouvements peut-être la même box
c'est pas alors c'est la même technique
c'est les mêmes règles
mais c'est pas la même pratique en fait
les femmes vont chercher plus la
condition physique
le cardio
le renforcement musculaire et pour moins
cher chez l'opposition elles sont plus
frileuses en général et donc avons
cherché à s'amuser et à pratiquer
différents vous êtes dit mme kadio
j'imagine c'est un sport aussi qui
entraîne une maîtrise de son corps aussi
une bonne connaissance
oui c'est un sport qui est très complet
en fait on utilise les membres
inférieurs pour les déplacements on a
besoin d'explosivité et on utilise les
membres supérieurs pour l'attaqué la
défensive donc là on a besoin également
de
la qualité physique et donc ça fait un
sport très très complète essayé bien sûr
un grand plaisir à léon dubois
allez on y va
[Musique]
et puis
un entraînement de boxe durent en
général deux heures il existe différents
styles à beaucamps un grand bravo à
notre journaliste mélanie poké chier il
faut remonter à mars 2005 pour observer
un tel phénomène avant léger redoux ce
week-end une vague de froid a traversé
la france cet hiver avec des
températures négatives et des ressentis
pourront aller jusqu'à -10 degrés dans
la région si certains ont peur de faire
du sport sous ces températures glaciales
d'autres au contraire les recherches
je vous propose de découvrir la méthode
wemhoff d'une honda néerlandais surnommé
l'homme de glace le concept les
débutants doivent apprendre à maîtriser
leur corps pour accepter le froid avec
des respirations avantage de jus
laughren ville une dizaine de minutes de
longue respiration une série de pompes
avant un bain dans de l'eau glacée avec
un bonnet pour conserver la chaleur
ces deux têtes je les applique depuis un
an la méthode wemhoff du nom d'un
néerlandais de 58 ans surnommé l'homme
de glace après cinq minutes dans l'eau
première réaction ce qu'on ressent ce
que c'est justement le fait qu'on soit
focalisée sur son souffle vata m en fait
d'apprécier bizarrement le le côté
vivifiant de l'eau et le côté froid donc
elle est vraiment forte tu le sens on le
sent tout de suite aux extrémités cessa
de le premier point faible entre
guillemets en fait qu'on va avoir c'est
des activités que sur les pieds et les
mains accepter le froid et ne pas
résister deux principes enseignés avant
de se lancer par cinq instructeurs en
france dont 1 dans les yvelines les
méthodes proches du yoga peuvent être
expliqués en huit journées aux personnes
en bonne santé médicale une attitude
corporelle relâcher les épaules
il ya une attitude à travers la
respiration c'est à dire si on rentre
dans l'eau sans entraînement on va être
complètement paniqué c'est à dire que le
cerveau passe en mode
peur primale ne peut pas le contrôle de
la respiration reprendre le contrôle
voilà et
et calmer le jeu pour que le corps
s'adapte et laisse faire ce qui doit se
faire selon les théoriciens de cette
méthode le système immunitaire serait
renforcée suite à cette exposition au
froid
au total cette discipline recense près
de 150000 à 200000 adeptes à travers le
monde et notamment aux états-unis en
australie dans les yvelines seulement
une dizaine de pratiquants sont recensés
évidemment ce type de performance n'est
pas à reproduire sans un entraînement à
confirmer et sans autorisation on passe
maintenant à l'agenda de ce week-end
[Musique]
de la course à pied dans cet agenda la
11e édition de l'eco trail est organisée
ce week-end avec au programme de la
marche nordique des randonnées et des
traits de 18 30 45 km un dernier de 80
km celui ci partira ce samedi à 12h15 de
l'île de loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines pour rejoindre la tour eiffel
en passant notamment par guyancourt
buquet vélizy villacoublay pour lui
parler à de ce rendez-vous nous recevons
sur ce plateau romain piot le directeur
events de l'eco trail de paris et fabien
à parmentier qui participera à l'épreuve
du 80 km bonsoir
alors combien de participants
attendez-vous sur 180 km en attend 2500
80 participants au départ du 80 des
parts du 80 et à l'est de plus en plus
de succès cette compétition là l'eco
trail de paris où elle plus en plus de
succès de la première année en 2008 on
avait 1500 participants au départ et là
on attend entre 12000 et treize mille
participants au total
fabien qu'est ce qui vous a attiré pour
participer à cette compétition comme
j'ai pu le dire l'année dernière ce que
vous m'avez fait venir il ya un an de ça
ici même moi c'était c'était déjà un
pari avec des amis le jour de mes 30 ans
et laval avait réalisé 11 épreuves sur
cause
alors pour l'instant 10 la 11e c'est
dans une semaine voilà et puis et puis
voilà donc là je viens d'avoir 40 ans
donc dix ans plus tard je suis encore là
et j'espère être le le premier grand
sénateur de l'eco-trail avoir fini
toutes les éditions alors la compétition
est baptisé eco trail pourquoi pourquoi
ils compteraient alors eco trail parce
que c'est un treuil et éco pour éco
responsable puisque de la depuis la
première année la création de l'éco
trail
tous nos parcours sont dans la nature
est en fait le schéma est assez simple
cd leur concours dans la nature il faut
pour la respecter si on la respecte pas
et à un moment il ya plus de nature et
signe a pu nature il n'y a plus rien
donc c'est la boucle vertueuse qu'on
essaie sur laquelle on essaie de
sensibiliser et d'éduquer tous nos
coureurs céder leur concours en nature
on se doit d'avoir un comportement
responsable
donc c'est donc un parcours qui
représente 92% de santi versé un
parcours agréable
fabien on qui avait l'habitude de faire
la passe et un parcours agréable de plus
en plus tous les ans effectivement il ya
des petites nouveautés mais on
s'aperçoit qu'effectivement les
organisateurs ont réussi à nous trouver
un parcours très agréable plutôt
vallonné il ya qu un dénivelé de 1500 m
m positif pardon mais plutôt vallonné il
faut toujours relancer donc pour un
coureur à pied un coureur nature c'est
un parcours qui est très ludique et très
agréable à courir y'a pas mieux que
l'île de loisirs saint quentin en
yvelines pour lancer l'épreuve dignement
il n'y a pas mieux c'est pour ça que
depuis la première année on lance le 80
km de là bas et on lance aussi de 45
kilomètres du château de versailles pour
arriver au pied de la tour eiffel un peu
plus simple de courir 45 km et enfin
qu'il est là c'est un peu plus simple
aurait alors demandé ce week-end mais
non non ça reste des préparations des
formats qu'il faut vraiment préparé pour
le cool 80 km il a la spécificité de de
secourir aussi de nuit pour la plupart
puisque le dernier concurrent arrive à
une heure du matin le dimanche donc il
faut pouvoir gérer le trail le dénivelé
positif possible de courir ennuis au
niveau sportif à bien le tracé fait de
80 km comment le prépare ce cas que tu
as eu 80 km alors pour ma part j'ai j'ai
maintenant l'habitude de m'entraîner
toute l'année donc j'ai pas un
entraînement spécifique est particulière
je m'entraîne tout temps de l'année mais
voilà on arrive à faire des sorties
spécifiques en semaine quand même c'est
à dire une a minima j'ai envie de dire
pour ma part ce sera trois sorties par
semaine plutôt des sorties en semaine le
sur paris le midi entre entre midi et
deux et puis une sortie longue le
week-end où là on essaye de rechercher
justement des terrains plus propice à
l'entraînement très laid telle nature
avec un petit peu de un petit peu de
côté parce que parce qu'il faut
s'entraîner sur ce type de deux chemins
et qu des descentes et puis exercé c'est
pareil c'est ses chevilles aux chemins
nature à savoir éviter les racines les
cailloux voilà encore pas sur du bitume
donc ça s'apprend et puis les les
articulations c'est pareil comment dire
ont besoin d'être entraînée à ce type
d'effort le premier de l'année dernière
avait couru le 80 km en 5 heures 48
minutes et 30 secondes à ce qu'on
pensait que c'est un record qui peut
être battu est ce que ça peut être battu
ce c'est un peu dans les tuer c'est ça
peut être battu d'autant plus que cette
année en fait on aura les 13 84 km heure
de moyenne
c'est rapide assez rapide sur 80
kilomètres surtout en fait il va il peut
être battu nous on l'espère parce que
cette année on aura on aura le plus le
plus grand plateau depuis la création de
l'eco-trail avec des coureurs nationaux
et surtout internationaux qui viennent
des crochets vouloir décrocher la
première place emmanuel gault qui lui a
gagné quatre fois l'eco-trail et le 80
km et je sais qu'il est temps c'est déjà
motivé a gagné son cinquième ce week-end
donc ouais ça peut être battu mais
l'arrivée sur le premier étage de la
tour eiffel et il le moment le plus
compliqué c'est le plus magique c'est
celui qui nous redonne le sourire après
80 km où vous faut le dire on en a quand
même bien bavé un généralement il ya
effectivement des élites pour qui 80 km
c'est c'est pas forcément grand chose on
est quand même une grande majorité à se
faire un petit peu mal sur ce genre de
course en faut pas se le cacher
l'arrivée au premier étage c'est
vraiment le la cerise sur le gâteau ça
nous redonne le sourire et puis est
comme ça on est on est on est prêt pour
vous repartirez une prochaine mais à la
question est-ce qu'il restait des places
des dossards encore sur ce 4e situation
le 80 non il reste plus de place
puisqu'on est complet il reste des
places sur le 18è le 30 km qui ont lieu
ce week-end aussi le dimanche donc pour
80 km faudra attendre la 12e édition
oui merci à tous les deux dépassé sur ce
plateau nous ferons un reportage complet
la semaine prochaine dans ce à 7,8 sport
et un dernier rendez vous à noter dans
votre agenda du week-end en football
billancourt reçoit à maurepas pour un
derby sulfureux en première division
district un choc dans ce championnat
entre les démos repas bien 2e du
classement et d'aiguillon courtois 5e
qui pointent à six points de leurs
adversaires
si vous voulez assister à la rencontre
l'entrée est libre c'est la fin de cette
émission très belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]